samuel leeds is one of britain's most
successful property entrepreneurs
a high-flying investor a best-selling
author and founder of a leading property
education company
samuel is recognized as one of the
brightest young stars in british
business
following his meteoric rise to success
by becoming a multi-millionaire in his
20s
samuel is in the elite echelons of uk
property investors
over the next five weeks 13 budding
property entrepreneurs
will be battling it out to prove that
they are the ultimate property investor
the prize twenty thousand pounds of
samuel's cold hard cash
to kickstart one candidate's property
journey
this is the eviction
[Music]
i know my stuff i started property with
no money 20k to me would give me a
really good kickstart into my property
journey i want to win
and i'll do anything i mean i'll do my
best at the moment i don't have any
properties so i'm in the very beginning
stages of my property journey
i actually just finalized on a deal with
my mum on
friday i've got a service accommodation
unit
and purchasing a property up north for a
refurb
a very cheap one i may add i can think
of all
options and all avenues my biggest
strength is confidence
doing the thousand doesn't seem like a
lot of money but it is
i am a bit of a perfectionist if i'm
gonna make something happen i'll go out
and get it so i started investing in
property
in roughly around september last year
i'm very motivated
i think i should win 20 000 pounds
because it will really help me excel in
my property
journey i think i deserve to win the
twenty thousand pounds my name is abby
pattison
i'm from york and i'm a property
investor
russell and alistair will be following
you
everywhere you go and helping me decide
who will win this life-changing prize
your first challenge will be this
morning
where you will visit a property that i
have secured
your job is to go to the property assess
the property
and package it up ready to sell it
tomorrow
and then tomorrow i'm going to be having
a party here at the castle
where 20 of my high net worth individual
friends
will be visiting and you will have an
opportunity
to present and sell your property deals
to the investors so we have two
properties
this is in east stoke on trent and this
property with the address on the keys
is in north stoke on trent i'll be
seeing you tomorrow
at the party in the meantime good luck
the girls arrive at their property to
see what they have to work with and how
best they can package it to sell to
their investors
if the numbers work and there's a
probability of a decent return
the team can sell the deal for a hefty
finder's fee
it's a big bathroom yeah very nice
meanwhile back at the castle the girls
are conjuring up a plan to sell the deal
to samuel's investors
at the pitch later on right so should we
just have a catch up see what we're all
start thinking with this property then
on the other side of stoke the boys take
a look around their property to evaluate
exactly what they have to sell to their
investors
[Music]
it looks um oh there's an alarm
we have smoke alarm yeah it's not a fire
alarm
no um it's a it's a decent sized garden
the fence needs to do it
samuel has invited 20 of his property
mates to the castle to watch the teams
pitch their deals in the hopes of
finding an investor
up first the boys who here
knows that their money is shrinking in
the bank
thank you prior to getting into property
i used to be a professional dancer
believe it or not oh elliot what are you
doing
we today are going to show you
well this is really awkward now uh what
we're about
i'm going to pass you over to john in a
second who
he's going to dazzle you with a deal and
everything is going to be a okay
thanks i think
who here thinks that 25 is is a good
deal within property
this fella doesn't look convinced
that will include a change of kitchen
windows liquid paints
and carpets a couple of the audience
giggling there at how ridiculous this
estimate is
we're talking about percentages which
actually sound pretty good on the face
of it
but i just like to know how much money
is needed in and what is the true
breakdown of that kind of like
a little bit you know fairly big picture
but a little bit line by line
so depending on the way that you're
going to finance it and what lenders you
use
that will really it will differ with the
numbers slightly
what's the deposit that's required as i
said there's other people in the room
that are
i i personally wouldn't be able to do
business with you yeah but i cannot get
a straight answer to a straight question
yeah no i i need to interject with that
straight away yeah i feel so
passionately about it
if i'm in a room with people and i'm
asking a question as an investor i
expect to get an answer otherwise it
just seems like you don't know it after
that dog's dinner of a performance from
the boys
it's the girl's turn to try and pitch
their deal to the investors
how many of you here today would be
interested in buying a property
if the return on investment was around
20
anyone the profit for the first 12
months would be six thousand
nine hundred cents a pound the roi would
be
19.5 and the investment total investment
in would be 36k
this property as we're seeing right now
is already
rented and now it has three great
bedrooms i mean each of the bedrooms
we're talking double bedrooms and there
is one that will take
a king-size bed i thought the um girl's
presentation was better than the boys
i thought they held their own a lot
better when we pressed them and standing
next to him stephen
i can't remember anything from stephen
okay so here's the verdict
um there's going to be a winning team
there's going to be a losing team
boys it's like you were trying to lose
the challenge
the deal was good but the the delivery
was not good at all so the girls are the
winning team
i think the first person that i'm gonna
evict
is steve off you go
elliot i think you're gonna do very very
well in business and in life
and it's with deep regret that you
aren't evicted
thank you very much i'm disappointed it
was me but it is what it is
um i was you know it's up to the other
people in the room and obviously samuel
on the team
[Music]
so yesterday you all made it through to
the second round so congratulations
the problem with a lot of deal packages
in today
is that they over promise in order to
sell the property
which can result in down the line
problems
now the boys sold their deal on the
basis
that the refurb cost could be just two
thousand pound
and the girls you said that for a refurb
it'll be eleven seventy
so your challenge here is your 1170
in cash you have until monday
at 5pm to refurb the property
understood boys
there's 2 000 pounds cash there are the
keys
monday 5 pm understood overseeing a
refurb like this
and getting your hands dirty is going to
be a valuable skill
that you need as a property entrepreneur
in order to even the numbers out a
little bit
i'm going to ask alicia and hannah
to move over to the boys team please
over at the boys property the massively
undervalued 2000 pound refurb
is underway
anthony calls his mum to see if she can
lend him a helping hand i've got this
huge refurb project
um and we've got like 48 hours to get it
completed
um so i kind of need my tools bringing
to newcastle is there any chance you can
bring them down to me
let's pop over and pay a visit to the
girls team leader nc is busy making sure
that the budget is in place before she
goes and splashes it all at one of her
favorite hardware stores which we can't
name for copyright
[Music]
you need reasons go shopping nc and
danny do a supermarket sweep looking for
furnishings for their property
nc returns back to the property after
it's been cleaned up a little bit
no way oh my goodness me
are you kidding me high five girl you go
girl
after a decent night's sleep we're back
at the boys house to see how they're
getting on
yeah we're on the landing we've done all
of the we've painted the whole house
ourselves we've been in here
working day and night we've got the
carpets going in this room here
um so they're just laying that down
there they're doing a great job of that
and it's going to look so fresh in there
after
i'll be honest we are i'll probably i'll
punch something if we don't win this
challenge because of all the work we've
put in
it's going to look good man and before
it was an overwhelming task for us
but once we clubbed together as a team
and we started to see like
results it spurred us on knowing that we
could do it
with the boys absolutely flying with
their refurb task
there's a storm brewing over with the
girls literally
all day yesterday it's just me courtney
and danny that i've done
most of the work and i can't believe
enzo's sent us to
telling us we're not even allowed to
spend money while she's gone she's not
here she don't obviously don't care what
we do
and she's telling us that we still can't
do anything when things need to be done
yeah what do you think of the wall
okay nc needs to go whether we win or
lose
when we match the dress bed all up
everything
everything in place yeah i think the
beauty will come out so
you don't like but do you think students
will like it it's
all do you like do you think students
would like it
you guys would know you guys said
students like things like these yeah
so yeah i think it's laughing so do you
worry that you're going to get evicted
i'm not talking about not discussing
that right now about if i win or not i'm
just focusing i'm going to focus on
getting this ready well yeah you're
going to focus on that more if you've
been here all day
eviction while we doing here right now
what it doesn't actually add no value to
me right now
what i've said about jake will you let
me finish please
shout out to me do not shout at me
don't you dare shout at
don't point can't look do not raise your
voice don't
do this in my face
do it don't do it listen you've had your
say wait wait
wait listen i want to speak to you i've
said things about you already said
you're not letting me finish
me finish excuse me let me finish you
can fit you've already finished
right well i was trying to be honest
with you if you said things
you're not letting me finish up
oh you're such a [ __ ] you are such a
[ __ ]
literally get out of my face you're
doing my head in i'm trying to be honest
with you but you won't even let me speak
you are
swearing at me
as if the drama couldn't get any worse
danny drops a whole tin of paint at the
top of the stairs
oh my god
[Music]
the boys have finished their refurb in
time and on budget of under 2 000
pounds this 4 bed hmo has been given a
new lease of life by the lads team which
includes new carpets painting throughout
and a blooming good scrub
it's been taken from a tired old
run-down student house
to a modern funky set of digs for a
relatively modest budget
this is crazy guys have done a [ __ ]
awesome job
you spent all of the budget two thousand
pound wow this just shows you what you
can do with a little bit of money
and hard work that's what's important
hard work
look what they've even done to the
windows now they didn't have enough
money in the budget to replace the
windows
but they've repaired them look solid
solid stuff before you bang it and it
was fall apart
because it was just so rotten i'm super
impressed
super impressed guys
[Music]
despite arguing like an old married
couple who quite frankly despise the
sight of one another
the girls have completed their refurb
within their 1170 pound budget
meanwhile despite the three days of
constant arguing with one another
the girls are still going at it to the
point where nc won't even entertain a
conversation
but the thing is you've said stuff about
me but everybody agrees with me
clearly you lacking the understanding
here in this whole situation
what they've done is they've tried to go
for a feature wall
but the thing is if you're going to
paint the wall bright orange
you need to at least have the cushions
to match not an off orange
that makes my balls itch
nc's team you had a very very simple job
which was just to decorate a house
there's six of you you had four days to
do it and you messed up
i was worried that there was going to be
a physical fight you had to paint
a house that was it paint a house you
had a budget that you
set the budget to paint the house for
you messed around
you didn't paint the house you argued
abby you clearly don't think antsy was a
good
james presented a good team later i
would agree with what abby said no
at no point do i think that anybody knew
what they were meant to be doing
what role was theirs no one knew what to
do
no one knew the budget why did none of
you have a clue yeah it comes down to
leadership
and see as team leader do you take
responsibility
for this task being a miserable fail
well i do because i i in
to a certain um
extent well it was a miserable fail you
were team leader
so then say you're evicted thank you
who should be evicted kirsten who failed
this task
okay kirsten you're evicted please leave
danny you've tried your best your best
has not been good enough
you've not given me a good reason why
you shouldn't be evicted so with regret
you're evicted
please leave
we all agreed that we didn't really have
um
good leadership in that task
unfortunately this is how it panned out
but that doesn't reflect in my work
ethic
anyway whatsoever my voice needed to be
heard
i do not stand for bully so no regret
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the third
challenge
up until this point you have been
completely spoon-fed
the properties have been secured by me
that you've had to refurb the investors
that you've sold deals to
have been put in place by me
things are about to change now and
you're not going to be spoon-fed and
things are about to get
a lot harder and more challenging
most of the successful companies in the
world know
that to profit from something they don't
have to own it
but rather they can just control it
that's why uber
don't own their taxis that's why
amazon don't own most of their stock
they control it
airbnb don't own most of their
accommodation
as a property entrepreneur you can make
significant amount of money
without owning property when you know
how to control it
so in this challenge you'll have to find
and secure
a no money down property deal
that you have complete control over
which is going to be making you a profit
this can be a rent to rent deal
or a lease option agreement property
so to even things out we're going to
move somebody over
ricky you were the previous team leader
so i'm going to give you five seconds
to tell me who is the weakest link on
this team
that you do not want to work with
anymore and we'll send them over go
alicia alicia
so you have three days i look forward to
seeing you in the boardroom
as part of this challenge you cannot tap
in
to any of your existing contacts you'll
be starting again
from scratch good luck off you go
the owners that are probably and we'll
have a look around with them no problem
at
all yeah perfect thank you what was your
name sorry sean brilliant i look forward
to hearing back from you
cheers thank you bye-bye
yes brilliant what's your name paul
thanks paul
boom boosh so what is it we're going to
view right
now so three bed uh hmo students
currently in it
and who are we going to meet guy called
alex
the landlord so he's just the four of
you a group of friends and you thought
we're all individual investors um and
we're working together
on some projects at the minute more
heads you know
make better work don't they and what's
the kind of the business model with
i kind of think of it as subletting or
taking it on and then
rent around yeah so with that basically
um
what we do is we take on properties from
landlords or
otherwise mainly landlords who just you
know want to keep the property of
capital appreciation things like that
we give them a guaranteed rent and then
look after maintenance tenants things
like that
okay um so it just means it's less
headache for them if we would come along
and say look we'll pay
we'll pay the rent that they're paying
at the moment yeah that you get anyway
um and then like we said we we did what
we would do
um i mean i know you said you like to be
hands-on and stuff would you
would you have an issue with that or no
okay
so you're quite open to the idea yeah
absolutely if we're going to be getting
what we would be getting and we
have one less house to worry about
yeah that's something you'd be able to
see is what you get just just to be
clear
50 pound of rooms that sort of
yeah that's why for the upstairs
or something like that in that vicinity
i think these
lease options have got the upper hand
over uh rent to rent just because you've
got the option to buy at the end
so you're gonna let the capital grow
that technically
is going to be the biggest return yeah
the team heads to a local networking
event in derby to try and find some more
deals
so we have just networked the hal
out of the meeting in derby um you know
we thought we're not gonna waste our
time today we need lease option deals we
need no money down deals we need rent to
rent deals
so we went in hard over with alicia's
team the guys are all staring aimlessly
at their laptop
seeing who can find the funniest online
cat videos
we've basically chosen an area and we're
just hammering it out right now to
schedule appointments for tomorrow
to go out richard says i like teams
hi there joe i'm looking for some
properties in the center of manchester
um
and do you know if the landlord would be
like if that would be something that's
okay with
or oh okay okay cole
yeah that's great yeah lovely that's
what i'm looking for
perfect yeah well we'll see you tomorrow
right now your number anyway
or anything criteria could you recall at
the start of day two with a bombardment
of viewings to see in properties to
secure
anthony leads hannah's team on the hunt
for those elusive no money down deals
i'm either going to sell them in the
future or or rent them
probably in an arrangement like yours
yeah yeah sure
you take on that so how how many
properties do you have
once i've sold this would be eight i'm
really passionate about property and i'm
really passionate about
um working and helping people like
yourself um
so you know i'm more than happy to to
travel a bit and
if it works for everyone then it's great
after trying to secure some deals on the
move the lads finally arrive in their
first viewing when stoke on trent hi
jason
good yeah thanks for taking your time
out today are you looking to move up do
you need the money now or
no you don't need the money now it's on
425
if we can get it for just the monthly
mortgage payments being covered
and in five years we'll give them 135
and we'll pay for a light refurb we'll
do it the next viewing for hannah and co
is a cosy two-bed terraced house in
worksworth
so yeah could put an offering today be
below 120 though
um or you're asking for one two five
i would buy it off you for
135 but in
five years time and over that five years
i would take over the property i'd
control it
um if you don't mind me i can ask you a
kind of a
not about your income or anything just
financial question about the mortgage
would that be okay
what how much uh the what's the amount
of the monthly mortgage payments
290 190 so i'd buy
in five years you're asking for one two
five i'll give you 135
in five years time i'd control the
property i take over you would still be
the landlord for the five years
but i would pay the mortgage payments
for you and it would be off your hands
stealing your name would take control of
it you'd have to deal with it we'll look
after it
and then in five years i'll have the
option to buy it for 135 000.
so i'll give you an extra 10 grand
does that sound any interesting to you
what were you still living it
we weren't living it we would um you
wouldn't be able to live in it
um it would basically be you'd have to
we have to bring tenants in if that
makes sense
so we would have to control the property
and rent it out well
i don't know i don't that's what i'll
have to look into yeah
sure hannah and anthony go and check out
one of three service departments which
could be used as corporate lets to
generate a monthly revenue
i i guess the easiest way to explain it
is it's like a normal tenancy in the
sense that
like patricia said they manage us um
they've got your best interest we've
also got your best interest but
obviously you know
patricia manages it for you um it's just
that the companies the tenant
instead no seriously they're beautiful
like amazing like really good
mate beautiful or not have we got a deal
we've got we've got a deal we just need
to negotiate the deposit the three
apartments
the three apartments are ours right and
they are
perfect prime essays they will honestly
they will rent out and you'll do really
really well from them one of them's
furnished two aren't furnished
um they're all two-bedroom you can get
six-person occupancy
they're slap-bang right near the city
center the only
only point is that um she's a bit wary
about the deposit now i spoke to her
manager
and i said look if we take all three we
do no deposit and she said
we might be able to angle it but the
only sticking point is there's three
different landlords
what we could do can we leverage it find
someone that's willing to put a deposit
in
and we give them a return every month a
small cut of what we're getting
to give them back their deposit and a
bit more so a massive turn up for
hannah's team
if they can get the deal over the line
meanwhile
alicia's team heading to day two on the
prowl for securing their own no money
down deals
i'd ring him at least twice
and don't tell me what to do it says
there are no
no license yeah rented times in our area
despite lease options being the most
lucrative of the two no money down
strategies
alicia and courtney try and secure some
new luxury flats to use as serviced
accommodation
okay yeah this uh this looks great yeah
yes on the phone yeah if they can do
that or if they can be there and we can
shake that
authority yeah as a selling agent yeah i
can
i can we would need proof of that even
if it's just an email yeah
that would be okay it did it come on
come on high five yeah rent to rent
this is like the best challenge ever i
cannot believe this is so
worthwhile we're probably gonna make
like 800 pound a month from the property
and it's a lazy option and we can buy it
and it's bmv and we can buy it five
years time oh stop i'm so excited
mate that is like and now we're going to
see some more all right so how did you
guys see
girl well yeah really good yeah we had a
really good time
you enjoyed it man honestly it's the
most fun i've had it shows you that
there's always something anywhere
yeah after a good few hours kip and a
hearty breakfast
the teams move on to day three of the
challenge with all of the deals for both
teams
only proverbially agreed can either team
secure the properties in time for the 5
pm deadline like i said
we're not in derby we're leaving this
afternoon so um
if we could get this sort of wrapped up
and sorted out the next few hours we
will really really appreciate that
they want they want the deposit john
pimps out the deals on facebook groups
to try and find an investor who can
input the 2000 pound they need to secure
a deposit for the rental essays
so what i'll do is i'll send you ahead
to terms um
over and then obviously i'll
transfer i'll give you the details of
the bank account and stuff like that
which we can sort it out
we're able to sort it out fairly quickly
so that we can um email the agent
secure today
yeah of course yeah yeah e a v
e r e r
would you take a second to appreciate
we've just secured
five apartments on a lease option
agreement
in two days
to potential 350 000
pounds in two days some of your leads
it's the boss said wait get to the crash
course
your challenge was to find a free house
a no money down deal
a lease option agreement or a rent to
rent and both teams
succeeded which is good so the deal that
you brought to the table
which was a no money down deal you'll be
making very good profit
it's five apartments yeah you've the
little money that you
might need you've demonstrated that you
can raise
you've actually got two thousand pounds
already in the bank
um i think that's that's very impressive
alicia's team have any of you guys got
lease option agreement properties that
you've secured
in real life before this challenge so
the fact that you've
been in property for what six twelve
months or so
and none of you have got any lease
option agreement properties
and now within the last few days you've
managed to get lease option agreement no
money down
rent to rents it's quite it's it's quite
shocking really
you you four have all been very strong
um
you're on the super winning team so
you guys are safe so you can go back to
the castle enjoy yourselves we've got
some treats planned for you off you go
thank you
and she had her moments where she was
kind of high or low and
yeah very high and low that's that's
exactly right and it was quite
you know you are they you know you are
they you're unpredictable
you're unpredictable but alicia
you didn't lead i don't think
you've got what it takes to win this so
with regret you're evicted
so here we are again james can't keep
doing this
you and somebody else you and somebody
else it's the third time it's happened
james we i don't think we can keep
having this conversation again and again
so with regret you're evicted off you go
[Music]
abby you're gonna have to be a bit more
predictable
a bit more stable i don't want to hear
you swearing at anybody
shouting at anybody i want to see you
sound minded
and continue doing what you're doing off
you go
ah you know when you hear that word it's
crushing
you know because you don't want to leave
the experiences are really amazing
it's it's not the end for me i'm going
home and i'm
i'm feeling good
i need to know who is worthy of winning
my
twenty thousand pound cash prize
so this challenge is when you'll be
putting together your business plan
and today russell and alastair are going
to be overseeing you do that
ready for when i'm going to bring in top
business analysts
who are going to go over your business
plans with a fine tooth comb
so like never before seen in any tv
business show ever
the candidates will have to compile a
business plan to demonstrate to a group
of successful business people
how they'd spend the twenty thousand
pounds if they were to win the
competition
i wanna make sure the business plans
look as good as possible and i don't
wanna see you guys getting ripped to
shreds
i do i want to use creative ways to
raise it okay
all right what are you going to use a 20
grand for oh yeah i'm confused as well
whether okay so
20 grand the reason why it is if you
articulate it like this in the business
plan
you're going to get ripped so what do
you want what do you want to do what do
you want to
what do you want how are you planning on
marketing
um i think i'm going to need to do some
research on that
my plan is to use the money to build a
multi-million pound
property portfolio that sounds like a
good plan he's actually just written
that
plan to build a multi-million pound
portfolio
what a great start yeah all right how
the heck are you going to take that
take 20 grand to multi-million pounds so
looking at your financial projections
yes
um i don't understand them okay as
simple as that
my plan is based on a service
accommodation unit
to um a service accommodation plan to
use as a cash cow
to basically invest money elsewhere so i
just want you to tell me
exactly why you should take
twenty thousand pounds of samuel's hard
earned cash
for your business one thousand pounds
can be spent on hotels and
travel so if i'm obviously networking
with investors
further afield from home i'm going to
need to spend some place
some money on hotels and things like
that
um sort of not exactly facebook ads but
you know things
i don't think i'd be using facebook ads
to start with but i would be later but
things like that so basically generating
the leads necessary
and the rest the rest um i think
i think it's about 21 pounds 60 for the
sage
accounting software what i'll need for
three months of use
you don't know john i do know that it's
seven pounds 20 per month
we're talking about 30 thousand pounds
yeah but i'm breaking down
sorry for it well christmas is coming
so i understand the 21 pounds a month
for sage
unbelievable pen ink dry
business plans scuppered but who'll face
the chop
in the boardroom
how did you do john i think it went okay
um
i do think that james highlighted
certain points uh which were quite
useful and i would take on the future
you want twenty thousand pound of more
money to spend a thousand pounds on
hotels
it basically but it would you know how
do you think i feel about you saying
i want twenty thousand pounds and a
thousand of it i want to spend on hotels
how do you think that makes me feel but
it would be
a holiday as well no no hotels is in
hotels for staying
um after going to networking events
staying over if i'm going trout i've
been traveling around further afield
from where my home
okay anthony wants to spend seven
thousand pounds
on videos
how can you justify that and today do
you know when i started my business
do you think i spent a penny on videos i
built up 10 000
followers on youtube on my phone have
you even done a video
i i've released i've put some videos how
many videos have you put out
um seven seven videos yeah on youtube
on youtube oh sorry two on youtube so
you put two videos on youtube
and and now you want and you said 150
pound a pop
per video where did you get that quote
from so i spoke to a videographer
and he said well you just rang one up
and like anthony if that was your money
your 20 000 pound would you really spend
150 pounds
a week on getting a video done or would
you just shoot it on your phone
i'd probably shoot it on my phone of
course so why do you think because it's
my money
you can spend it on a videographer that
you just picked up off google
first person you spoke to i wanted to
use the money to invest it
now the truth is you don't know what
you're going to invest the money in you
don't have any idea
and in fact most of you are just
clutching at straws trying to think of
stuff oh what can i spend this 20 grand
on well maybe i could throw a few grand
on infusionsoft
three thousand pound on infusion stuff
it's ridiculous is that is that not
ridiculous
i can see where you're coming from no
not you can see where i'm coming from
why would you not use mailchimp which is
free why do you want to use infusionsoft
when you're just starting out
it's beyond me thing is if it was your
money you wouldn't be doing that
if it was the your hard earned 20 000
pound you would be starting with
whatever's free
what i wanted to do was to grow my
business quicker and to buy more i spent
it by spending
seven grand over 12 month period doing a
weekly video come on mate
come on mate are you stupid you're not
stupid you're an intelligent guy
you've been you've been you've had like
four three four days to do this business
plan
what were you thinking i was thinking if
i spent the money
on more expensive marketing tools i
would be able to grow my bank well
that's how business works i'm afraid
it's just not how business works and i
think that's a
schoolboy error i was thinking i can't
wait to go over the business plans
they're going to be great i really want
to give someone a break i really want to
give someone twenty thousand pound that
deserves it twenty thousand pound in
your pocket tomorrow
what are you gonna spend it on i mean
there will be marketing involved
because we have to reach clients okay so
how much of it are you gonna spend on
marketing
maybe a few thousand pounds maybe a few
thousand pound a little bit of marketing
it's twenty thousand pound
so okay three thousand pound marketing
then what you can do the seventeen
thousand pounds
i've got uh the ongoing starting cost
throughout the year like
um a professional accountant that knows
about the property
probably industry but the thing is with
an accountant you pay an accountant
once you've made money and then you pay
them to your books at the end of the
year
the check the channel manager is going
to need paying as well is that a monthly
thing
yep no you said you need money to start
the business and you're giving me
ongoing costs
like accountancy costs
you don't need the twenty thousand pound
to stop to start the business
what are you gonna do start the business
anyway and then use the twenty thousand
pound to go to barbados for a few weeks
is that your plan
no what's your plan then or do you not
have a plan
can you see why i'm struggling here i
can't ricky you're evicted
off you go
i feel like it's the wrong decision okay
well you had your opportunity so off you
go
john what are you going to do with 20
000 pounds um
so my aim was to set up a sourcing
company um would you
set up a sourcing company to um well i
would
set up a company where i would source
properties for instance i know what it
means
i'm asking where the money would go so
the money would go into
lead generation it would go into
lead generation um obviously you can do
a lot of things for free in that i can
go around to estate agents i can do
viewers
i set my source and coming up with 2 000
pounds
one of the biggest sourcing companies in
the uk yeah what are you gonna do with
your twenty thousand pounds
i would spend um now i would spend ten
thousand on setting up the sourcing
company
john you're evicted thank you
it doesn't cost 10 000 do you know the
annoying thing is if it was your
personal money
you would all change your business plan
you would all change what you're going
to do because when you start a business
you start business with as little money
as possible
not just willy-nilly blowing 20 grand
there's 20
000 pounds on the line here i understand
you're not fighting for your corner
there's no passion in you do you
actually want this i feel like i'm the
strongest
candidate i've spent three days over
this weekend
really motivated level-headed i know
that there's been errors in the business
plan
yeah over these three days yeah where
you were able to not work as a team
and lock yourself in your room you've
been level-headed but when you're
working as a team you've been shouting
at people you've been getting emotional
for this task i have been the strongest
candidate over the weekend because
other people have been complaining have
been wanting to give what is stronger
than that
i know my my plan will work um because
this strategy
what would you like me to do to convince
you i'm not gonna spoon feed you buddy
i'm not convinced based on what is said
in the bedroom it does sound quite
um messy i don't really understand do
you do
it from the bandwagon do you understand
the buy refurbished you find that
strategy
do you understand how i'm going to put
my money into a property so tell me why
it wouldn't work
how are you going to escalate that into
a bigger business
simple if an investor invests into one
of my products
i'll take that money i'll buy a property
i'll refurbish the property i'll
refinance and give them their money back
i'll get another investor and do the
same thing again
you can't count on refinancing a
property though so
so i have an exit strategy if the pro
property doesn't refinance out of the
value i expect it off
then the investor gets an option two
options they can leave their money in
for three years
and gain capital uplift on the property
or they can get a 10
return on the remaining prop money in
the property until the money's paid back
it's a safe investment for an investor
because they're going to get a great
return
when i do all the work and at the end of
it i end up with with a
portfolio of houses you're evicted
[Music]
i'm super super grateful for having an
opportunity to be here i tried my
hardest and there's nothing more i could
really have done with it
our business plans got absolutely ripped
apart
only two candidates remain 11 candidates
have fallen by the wayside
but can the two finalists hold their
nerve as the race to be crowned champion
unravels in this thrilling series finale
it's killing me
we'll slash this right
are you guys feeling nervous
i know last time when we were in the
boardroom i put too much detail in the
business planning
put too much detail
wasn't too detailed it just sucked okay
and you've
you've taken on the feedback that we
gave you about that and you've now
presented those with a six or seven page
plan um yeah top job hannah let me ask
you a question
i mean it's a this is a good business
plan you know anthony you've worked with
him
you know his strategy what do you see
any flaws in this
no i think i think i think it's very uh
i think it's a safer
strategy than the one that i'm adopting
um in terms of the fact that he's
actually
investing his money in capital
appreciation but one thing that i would
say
is that my business plan is
interchangeable
so anthony's business plan is focused on
buying a property i just haven't had the
money to
to pull out it's a little bit still all
over the place there isn't really no
sure not
i appreciate that but i genuinely think
that the business plan that i've put in
front of you can generate more income
show me the business plan
i don't have my business plan on me no
it just doesn't look great
look i i i yeah i completely understand
i'm disappointed
in the fact that i i i didn't bring it
i'm terribly sorry about that i can only
apologize
so have you not brought have you not
brought with you
the figures for the house that you'll
want us to you know
like this have you bought your own as in
my actual house the figures
as in the far well anything any evidence
of what you're going to actually what
have you been doing the last two weeks
of the business plan is the exact same
what have i been doing so i've been
making sure that the apartments
are when they're going to be ready and
to view them and making sure
um that everything's agreed for them and
and what i'm going to do in terms of
management agents and and things like
that i think expecting a struggle is the
fact that
you've you know you've seen anthony's
pitch you've heard his business plan
and you've said yes anthony's is really
good yeah yes mine's risky
yes mine's all over the place i know
what i'm doing with service
accommodation i know that it will work
i know the figures because i run a
studio apartment that's not too far from
there
it makes a lot of profit and i know that
this will work and in terms of the
return on investment of the money that
you're going to give me
i know that my return on investment will
be higher than anthony's business plan
it will
generate a higher roi i don't think
by anthony buying two houses will change
his life i don't think that amount of
money will change his life that
drastically
and i think that his business plan is
very good and i think it's very safe
and i do think mine's riskier but i
think that
mine uh the twenty thousand pounds will
change my life i don't think it would
change anthony's and i think that
when you see what i can do with it and
where i'll be in 12 months time
i think you'll agree with it um and
hopefully after
seeing me and the way that i've operated
and the fact that i wasn't in any
boardroom i didn't lose on any team
um throughout this whole process will
hopefully give you a good indication of
the person i am
and that your money will be safe and
very well invested for me this 20 000
pound isn't just for me you know
the purpose of why i want to do this
strategy is because i want to build
houses for people to live in
you know the the disgusting house that
we went into
people were living in that house and
that's why i want to refurb these to
this quality and that's why the 20 000
pound will change my life
because it's not just for me it's for
the other people that i'm going to put
in these houses
what what do you care about why do i
care because
i have been in that situation i've been
in that situation
where i have had nothing and i've been
put in a house that's disgusting
with mold on the wall you know and my
landlord didn't care about me
we are becoming a nation of renters you
know people haven't got the opportunity
to buy houses anymore
they they're not presented with
opportunities like this where they might
change their lives and have them
money to buy houses but i am so i'm
going to use it
properly you know and and change
people's lives
i think the thing is obviously the 20
000 pound
that i'm going to give one of you today
is a gift
it's not an investment you could say but
at the same time although it's it's no
strings attached
of course i want to see yeah i want to
see as much change as i can
i'm an investor so although i'm not
going to be getting a financial gain
from it i'll be getting a satisfaction
gain
should we have a few minutes to have a
chat and and call them back in
but as i say before you leave the
building today one of you will be 20 000
pound
richer so if you give us a few minutes
that'd be great thank you
[Music]
hi samuel hi uh abby can you come
through to the boardroom please
yes sure thank you
can you please send twenty thousand
pounds across to this account
thank you
[Music]
it's not been an easy decision
[Applause]
one of you is going to walk away
with 20 000 pounds do you think it
should be you and tonight
yes how did you think it should be yeah
100
without the money the process of the
eviction
well how is that going to help you it's
it's helped me develop
massively as a person um the business
plan that i presented to you
everything everything in now when i was
contemplating it
there's all stages of things that have
happened through the eviction so it's
really helped me grow
as a person and i'm going to be forever
thankful for that
how about you hannah yeah knowledge and
confidence
like the the particular task where we
had to go out and find
no money down deals lease options i've
never touched them before
and the confidence to literally go out
there and go direct to estate agents and
ask for things like that
and the relationships that i built with
the other contestants i mean
a couple of us potentially may even go
into business with each other further
down the line which is which is really
cool
i mean i think you're both extremely
strong
and we we were even talking about oh my
goodness could we just give it to both
of them
you know because you're both fantastic
and
whatever happens moving forward you're
both going to receive
a lot of help and support from us both
personally and
you know in every way possible really um
the question is who have i decided
to transfer my 20 000 pound money to
abby is the money actually in the
account
so right now there has been 20 000
pounds
transferred into anti's account
congratulations thank you so much thank
you
thank you that's amazing thank you so
much and i really appreciate the help
that you guys have given me
along the journey um and i won't let you
down with this
you know it's gonna be amazing to show
you what i get to do with this
hannah you've been a fantastic
contestant and we're gonna support you
and work with you
anthony well done thank you
congratulations
what is this thank you thank you
thank you well done thank you good job
thanks really appreciate it
thank you
sorry oh goodness
i was so emotional yeah do you know what
it is
yeah go on it's it's emotional because
ah sometimes when you feel like you got
[Music]
the weight of other people on you just
wanted to do it
that's right i think it was um a good
result an end for anthony
anthony's a very deserving winner um
the problem we got is there were two
super strong candidates they both got
very different business plans
so um so i've just won twenty thousand
pound i cannot believe it i'm
absolutely over the moon i did think
there was a moment that um
hannah would won um you know and i would
have been so pleased for her but i just
knew what this meant to me
um i'm so happy i just can't explain it
although
it feels horrible at the moment
at this moment in time he's
he's a really great guy and
genuinely pleased him his business plan
was epic um
and he pulled out the bag massively over
like the last week
mine pretty much stayed the same but his
business plan that he came in there with
and his roi and things like that and
samuel even asked me asked me would i
invest in it and i would
i would so this is the beginning
of a bigger journey so
[Applause]
[Music]
throughout the eviction process you've
seen 13 people
on their journey to financial freedom
and i'm very passionate about helping
people which is why i train thousands of
people
every single year to become property
investors so if you'd like to become a
property investor
then you can join me at the property
investors crash course
which is a free program where you can
learn the skills to start your journey
to financial freedom
[Music]
[Music]
you